da sind wir clixoom aber auch andere
medien wie der berliner tagesspiegel
oder der österreichische kurier einem
alten video aufgesessen dieses video
zeigt zwar wahrscheinlich eine explosion
in russland aber nicht die atomexplosion
in europe sa
das hat das internetportal korrektiv
herausgefunden es hat unser video
analysiert und die herkunft im jahr 2015
ausgemacht von den extrusions bildern
unabhängig davon hat die explosion
stattgefunden und es gibt messungen von
radioaktivität jetzt in norwegen tricks
und science fiction hier gibt's täglich
faszinierendes eines videos abonniert
den kanal aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht erst mal
vielen dank an corrective dort auch für
die detaillierte und saubere analyse
gut dass es solche organisationen gibt
und wir wollen es eben transparent
machen wenn wir etwas gezeigt haben das
so nicht stattgefunden hat ganz wichtig
vorab an den recherchen gab es keine
korrekturen das ist richtig aber wir
werden ernsthafte zweifel immer
verfolgen und eben auch veröffentlichen
damit er sicher sein können dass das was
hier berichtet wird auch korrekt ist
herzlich willkommen
wie gesagt keine korrekturen an der
recherche sondern am video tatsächlich
das hat corrective dot org
herausbekommen handelt es sich bei dem
video das wir gezeigt haben und das in
artikeln auf der webseite des
tagesspiegels oder beim kurier
eingebunden ist um einen ausschnitt aus
einem alten video und das stammt aus dem
jahr 2015 ist also vier jahre alt es
kann also so oder so nicht den
atomunfall zeigen ich weiß ein video
sagt mehr als tausend bilder ein bild
mehr als 1000 worte wir sind unglaublich
beeindruckend und deshalb haben wir
dieses video hier gerne gezeigt und den
quellenangaben geglaubt im titel heißt
es nämlich zugegebenermaßen etwas
kryptisch in den apotheken von
archangelsk und sewerodwinsk wurde nach
der explosion eines strahlt triebwerks
jod gekauft es sollte also der eindruck
erweckt werden dass es sich um den
aktuellen atom unfall handeln würde auch
in einem russischen nachrichtenbeitrag
über den aktuellen atom unfall hat
corrective das video entdeckt das video
ist also wirklich alt und hat nichts mit
dem aktuellen atom unfall zu tun
der vielleicht viel harmloser oder viel
schlimmer ausgesehen hat wir werden es
wahrscheinlich nie erfahren
es gibt es zum ersten mal messung
radioaktiver strahlung die
wahrscheinlich von diesem unfall stammen
in norwegen und diese messung zeigt
schwache radioaktivität damit liegen zum
ersten mal daten vor dass schon bald
ermittelt werden kann was da wie und mit
welchen auswirkungen explodiert ist das
hat jetzt auch eine studie über den
atomunfall in majak in russland 2017
gezeigt der sogar gänzlich von russland
geleugnet wird aber eben
nachgewiesenermaßen stattgefunden hat
ich bin sehr gespannt was es mit dem
aktuellen unfall auf sich hat wie die
forschenden dem atomunfall 2015 auf die
spur gekommen sind das erfahrt ihr in
diesem video anklicken anschauen um
klicks und science fiction abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran